I step off the drum kit and I put my
foot in a in a strap I just jump on it
and go
and there's a guy down below with the
handbrake I don't feel the handbrake
kick in and I'm like oh [__] something
wrong
so I just decide I pull my foot out of
the strap and I figure try to land like
a cat or something and I slammed my head
on the concrete of the Arena floor
out concussion out damn show's over uh I
wake up in in the ambulance I was like
what happened they're like oh dude take
it easy you just you just had a crazy
crazy fall I'm like oh I gotta I gotta
get back there we're gonna [__] show
to finish right and they're like no no
no no dude no that's a negative